Así que me fui al campo de refugiados.
Y cuando fui al campamento de refugiados en Pakistán,
había 7.5 millones de refugiados.
7.5 millones de refugiados.
Alrededor del 90 % eran mujeres y niños.
La mayoría de los hombres habían muerto o estaban en la guerra.
Y en el campo de refugiados,
al estudiar día tras día la situación,
encontré cosas que nunca hubiera imaginado.
Vi a una viuda con de cinco a ocho niños
sentada allí y llorando
sin saber qué hacer.
Vi a una mujer joven sin tener a dónde ir,
sin educación, sin entretenimiento, ni siquiera un lugar para vivir.
Vi a muchachos que habían perdido su padre y su hogar,
y que apoyaban a su familia siendo niños de 10 a 12 años
como cabeza de familia,
tratando de proteger a su hermana y su madre y sus hijos.
Así que fue una situación muy devastadora.
Mi corazón latía por mi pueblo,
y yo no sabía qué hacer.
En ese momento, hablamos de impulso.
En ese momento, sentí, ¿qué puedo hacer por estas personas?
¿Cómo podría ayudarlas?
Soy un individuo. ¿Qué puedo hacer yo por ellos?
Pero en ese momento, supe
que la educación cambió mi vida.
Me transformó. Me dio estatus.
Me dio confianza. Me dio una carrera.
Me ayudó a mantener a mi familia,
traer a mi familia a otro país,
por su seguridad.
Supe en ese momento
que lo que debía darle a mi gente era educación y salud,
y eso es lo que hice después.
Pero ¿creen que fue fácil?
No, porque ahí, la educación fue prohibida para las niñas, por completo.
Y también, como consecuencia de la invasión de Rusia a Afganistán,
la gente no confiaba en nadie.
Fue muy duro ir y decir: "Quiero hacer esto".
¿Quién soy?
Alguien que viene de EE. UU.
Alguien que consiguió educado aquí.
¿Ellos confiaban en mí? Por supuesto que no.
Así que en realidad necesitaba construir confianza en esta comunidad.
¿Cómo voy a hacer eso?
Fui y examiné y miré y miré.
Pregunté.
Finalmente, encontré un hombre.
Tenía 80 años.
Era un mullah.
Fui a su tienda de campaña en el campamento,
y le pregunté:
"Quiero hacerle maestro".
Y él me miró,
y dijo: "Mujer loca,
mujer loca, ¿cómo crees que puedo ser maestro?".
Yo le dije: "Voy a hacerle maestro".
Finalmente, aceptó mi oferta,
y una vez que inicié una clase en su recinto,
la voz se extendió por todas partes.
En cuestión de un año,
teníamos 25 escuelas establecidas,
15 000 niños yendo a la escuela,
y fue increíble.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Pero, claro, hacíamos todo nuestro trabajo, formábamos al profesorado.
Enseñábamos derechos de las mujeres, derechos humanos,
democracia, Estado de Derecho.
Dábamos todo tipo de formación.
Y un día, le cuento,
un día estaba en la oficina en Peshawar, Pakistán.
De repente, vi a mi gente llegar corriendo a las habitaciones y cerrando las puertas
y me dicen, "Huye, ¡escóndete!".
Y ya saben, como líder, ¿qué haces?
Tienes miedo. Sabes que es peligroso.
Sabes que su vida está en la línea.
Pero como líder, tiene que mantenerlo unido.
Hay que mantenerlo unido y mostrar fuerza.
Así que dije: "¿Qué está pasando?".
Y estas personas estaban invadiendo mi oficina.
Así que los invité a la oficina.
Entraron, y eran nueve, nueve talibanes.
Eran los hombres más feos que se puedan ver.
(Risas)
Personas que parecían muy malas,
ropa de color negro, turbante negro,
y entraron en mi oficina.
Les invité a tomar asiento y el té.
Dijeron que no. No iban a tomar té.
Y, por supuesto, por el tono de voz que estaban utilizando,
estaba aterrada,
estaba realmente temblando.
Pero también era fuerte, aguantándome.
Y, por supuesto, en ese momento, ya saben cómo me visto...
Me visto de pies a cabeza en un hiyab negro.
Lo único que se podía ver eran mis ojos.
Me preguntaron: "¿Qué está haciendo?
¿No sabe que la escuela está prohibida para las niñas?
¿Qué está haciendo aquí?".
Yo los miraba a ellos,
y yo dije: "¿Qué escuela? ¿Dónde está la escuela?"
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Y me miran a la cara, y me dicen: "Usted está enseñando niñas aquí".
Les dije: "Esta es una casa cualquiera.
Tenemos algunos estudiantes que vienen,
y todos están aprendiendo el Corán, el Libro Sagrado.
Uds. saben, el Corán dice que si uno estudia el Libro Sagrado, la mujer,
puede ser una buena esposa,
y puede obedecer a su marido".
(Risas)
Y les digo una cosa:
esa es la forma de trabajar con esas personas...
(Risas)
Así que en ese momento, comenzaron a hablar pashto.
Hablaron entre sí,
y dijeron: "Vámonos, dejémosla sola, ella está bien".
Esta vez les ofrecí té de nuevo,
y tomaron un sorbo y reían.
En ese momento, mi personal viene a mi oficina.
Estaban muertos de miedo.
No sabían por qué no me mataron.
No sabían por qué no me quitaban.
Pero todo el mundo estaba feliz de verme.
Muy feliz, y yo estaba feliz de estar viva, por supuesto.
(Risas)
Por supuesto, estaba feliz de estar viva.
Pero también, al continuar la formación durante la caída de los talibanes...
claro, durante los Talibanes era otra historia.
Era bajo tierra y dábamos educación a 80 alumnas,
3 000 estudiantes bajo tierra, y continuamente los educábamos.
Con la caída de los talibanes, entramos en el país,
y abrimos escuela tras escuela.
Abrimos un centro de aprendizaje para mujeres.
Continuamente abrimos clínicas.
Trabajamos con las madres y los niños.
Dimos educación en salud reproductiva.
Tuvimos todo tipo de educación que puedan imaginar.
Estaba muy feliz. Estaba encantada con el resultado de mi trabajo.
Y un día, con cuatro entrenadores y un guardaespaldas,
iba al norte de Kabul,
y de pronto, de nuevo,
fui detenida en medio de la carretera
por 19 jóvenes.
Con rifles en sus hombros, bloquearon el camino.
Le dije a mi chofer, "¿Qué está pasando?".
Y el conductor dijo: "No sé".
Les preguntó. Dijeron: "No tiene que ver con usted".
Me llamaron por mi nombre. Dijeron: "Nosotros la queremos".
Mi guardaespaldas salió, dijo: "Yo puedo responderles.
¿Qué quieren?".
Dijeron: "Nada". Me llamaron por mi nombre.
Y en ese momento, las mujeres estaban gritando y gritando dentro del coche.
Estaba muy conmovida, y me dije, esto es todo.
Esta vez, nos van a matar a todos.
No había duda en mi mente.
Pero aún así, el momento llega, y se toma fuerza
de lo que creas y lo que hagas.
Está en tu corazón.
Crees que vale la pena, y se puede caminar sobre ello.
Así que me apoyo en el lado del coche.
Mi pierna estaba temblando, y salgo.
Y les pregunté: "¿Qué puedo hacer por Uds.?".
¿Saben lo que me dijeron?
Dijeron: "Sabemos quién es Ud.
Sabemos a dónde va.
Todos los días van hacia al norte, aquí y allá.
Ud. entrena mujeres, les enseña
y también se les da la oportunidad de tener un trabajo.
Ud. construye sus habilidades. ¿Qué hay de nosotros?".
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
"Y entonces, ¿qué hay de nosotros?
¿Qué vamos a hacer?".
Los miré y le dije: "No sé".
(Risas)
Ellos dijeron: "Está bien.
Lo único que podemos hacer, lo que sabemos,
desde el momento en que nacemos, tenemos un arma y matamos.
Es todo lo que sabemos".
Y saben eso qué significa.
Es una trampa para mí, por supuesto.
Así que salgo de allí. Dicen: "La vamos a dejar ir".
Y así que entré en el coche, me siento en el coche,
y le digo al conductor, "De la vuelta y regrese a la oficina".
En ese momento, solo apoyábamos niñas.
Solo teníamos dinero para entrenar mujeres,
para enviarlas a la escuela, y nada más.
En el momento en que llegué a la oficina,
por supuesto mis entrenadores se habían ido.
Huyeron a casa. Nadie se quedó allí.
Mi guardaespaldas era el único que estaba,
y mi voz había desaparecido por completo.
Yo estaba conmocionada, y me senté en mi mesa,
y dije: "¿Qué voy a hacer?
¿Cómo voy a resolver este problema?".
Porque ya entrenábamos pasando al norte.
Cientos de mujeres fueron allí para capacitarse.
Así que estaba sentada allí, y de repente, en ese momento,
hablando de impulso, somos,
en ese momento,
una de mis donantes maravillosas me llamó acerca de un informe.
Y ella me preguntó: "¿Sakena?" Y yo le contesté.
Ella dijo: "No eres tú. ¿Qué te pasa?".
Dije "Nada". Traté de ocultarle.
No importaba lo que tratara de hacer, ella no me creía,
y ella me preguntó de nuevo.
"Está bien, dime ¿qué está pasando?".
Le conté toda la historia.
En ese momento dijo: "Está bien, la próxima vez, ayúdales.
Ve a ayudarles".
Y cuando, dos días más tarde, fui por la misma ruta,
no estaban allí,
estaban un poco más atrás,
los mismos jóvenes, de pie allí y sosteniendo el rifle
y señalándonos para detener el coche.
Así que paramos el coche.
Salí. Les dije: "Bueno, vengan conmigo".
Y ellos dijeron: "Sí".
Les dije: "Con una condición, que todo lo que digo, lo aceptan".
Dijeron que sí, que lo harían.
Así los llevé a la mezquita,
y para hacer el cuento corto,
les dije que les daría maestros.
Hoy en día, son los mejores entrenadores.
Aprenden inglés,
aprenden a ser maestros,
aprenden computadoras,
y son mis guías.
Cada área que es desconocido para nosotros en las zonas montañosas,
van conmigo. Ellos van adelante vamos.
Y ellos nos protegen.
Y...
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Eso te dice que la educación transforma a las personas.
Cuando se educa a la gente,
van a ser diferentes,
y hoy por todas partes,
tenemos que trabajar por la igualdad de género.
No solo podemos formar a las mujeres, y olvidar a los hombres,
porque los hombres son los que de verdad
les dan a las mujeres sus momento más difíciles.
(Risas)
Así que empezamos a entrenar hombres porque los hombres deben conocer
el potencial de las mujeres,
saber cuánto potencial tienen los hombres,
y cuánto de ese mismo trabajo que están haciendo, lo pueden hacer las mujeres
Así que estamos dando continuamente formación a los hombres,
y realmente lo creo firmemente.
Vivo en un país que era un hermoso país.
Solo quiero compartir esto con Uds.
Fue un hermoso país,
un país hermoso, pacífico.
Íbamos en todas partes.
Las mujeres estaban recibiendo educación:
abogadas, ingenieras, profesoras,
e íbamos de casa en casa.
Nunca cerrábamos nuestras puertas.
Pero saben lo que le pasó a mi país.
Hoy, la gente no puede salir de su casa sin problemas de seguridad.
Pero queremos el mismo Afganistán que teníamos antes.
Y quiero mostrarles el otro lado.
Hoy en día, las mujeres de Afganistán están trabajando muy, muy duro.
Están ganando grados. Están estudiando para ser abogadas.
Están estudiando para ser médicas, otra vez.
Están estudiando para ser maestras,
y están dirigiendo empresas.
Por eso es tan maravilloso
ver a la gente así, alcanzar su total potencial,
y todo esto va a pasar.
Quiero compartir esto con Uds.,
por amor,
debido a la compasión,
y debido a la confianza y la honestidad.
Si uno tiene estas pocas cosas consigo
lo logrará.
Tenemos un poeta, Mawlana Rumi.
Dijo que teniendo compasión
y amor, se puede conquistar el mundo.
Y yo les digo que pudimos.
Y si pudimos hacerlo en Afganistán,
estoy segura al 100 % de que todo el mundo
puede hacerlo en cualquier parte del mundo.
Muchas, muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
Gracias. Gracias.